We are continuing to very closely look
at the December 6 Georgia runoff between
incumbent Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock and challenging Republican uh
candidate Herschel Walker now we've
already talked about how Herschel Walker
has no business uh being senator from
Georgia I'm going to give you yet
another example of that a little bit
later on in the show but one of the
interesting questions has been is Donald
Trump going to show up to try to help
Herschel Walker Barack Obama is showing
up to try to help Rafael Warnock
that we know and he will be campaigning
with him but Donald Trump is apparently
so toxic at this point in time that
Republicans are trying to keep him as
far away from Georgia and as far away
from Herschel Walker as possible New
York Times reports Trump plans limited
role in Georgia Senate runoff the former
president who held two big rallies
before the state's two runoff elections
two years ago both of which Democrats
won will steer clear of Georgia
before next week's senate election and
when you look at why
you very quickly understand it
a Michael Bender writes for the New York
Times Donald Trump will not cross the
Florida state line to campaign with
Herschel Walker during the final week of
the Georgia Senate runoff election after
both camps decided the former
president's appearance carried more
political risks than rewards campaign
officials for the two Republicans said
Monday do we believe that Trump was
sitting there going you know what it's
true I've become such a ticking time
bomb and hot head and liability that
it's probably best that I not go
probably not it's probably the people
around Trump
who got together with those running
Walkers campaign and said we're going to
try to keep them away Trump is planning
a call with supporters and will continue
sending online fundraising please for
Walker now those online fundraising
please default to 90 of the money
actually going to Trump and here is sort
of the key line of the article the
decision to keep Trump out of the
spotlight was a response largely to the
former president's political style and
image which can energize his core
supporters but also motivate Democratic
voters and turn off significant segments
of moderate Republicans one other really
interesting element of this in Georgia
that political math has become a net
deficit for Trump
that's a critical line
who opened his 2024 presidential
campaign two weeks ago in 2020 he was
the first Republican presidential
candidate to lose the state in 28 years
earlier this year his hand-picked
primary Challengers Governor Brian Kemp
and Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger were both trounced this is
more interesting
in terms of 2024. now I don't want to
diminish the importance of getting that
51st senate seat in Georgia
the data is looking pretty good for
Raphael Warnock we never count our
chickens before they CA hatch we never
um you know you use whatever metaphor
you want
that is an election we have to fight for
we're going to be covering it including
up to uh the live results on December
6th
but there's another component to this
which is
what is Trump's path to victory in 2024
and what I mean by that is if you start
with the 2020 map and you say what was
marginal here you certainly look at
Georgia now the problem with that math
is flipping Georgia alone from 2020
won't give Trump the presidency so you
need Georgia and something else or you
got to flip Pennsylvania
George is increasingly looking bad for
Trump and part of that signal
is exactly what's happening in Georgia
right now so when we think about can
Trump win and listen I was one of the
guys that a week before the 2016
election said I think Hillary's got it
in the bag and I was wrong so I am not
going to fall for this again
particularly two years early and say oh
Trump has no path to victory in 2024.
the difference is we've seen what a
trump map looks like
and Georgia is an important part of that
map George is an important signal when
we think about 2024 and George is
looking so bad for Trump that he's being
kept away when it comes to Herschel
Walker that's why it's so critically
important right now let me know what you
see as Trump's map and path to Victory
there
um and maybe we'll even do we're not
going to do maps between now and
November of 2024 but maybe we'll do one
sample map to sort of look at what it
could be send me your thoughts make sure
that you are subscribed on YouTube make
sure that you are following us on
Facebook at facebook.com davidpackman
show much new content coming the white
paper on how to talk politics without
ruining relationships is now available
at davidpackman.com guide a thousand
people have already downloaded this I am
stunned we were thinking well if 250
people download this thing it's probably
a good start a thousand people have
already downloaded this guide it is free
at davidpackman.com guide one of our
sponsors is monk pack making amazing
granola bars and the nut and Seed bars
that are chewy Sweet and delicious but I
especially love them because each bar
has only one gram of sugar two to three
net carbs and about 150 calories perfect
if you do keto or low carb or like me
you're just trying to stay conscious
about sugar intake you get the
satisfying crunchy salty sweet
experience you were looking for without
the sugar monk pack comes in flavors
like sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea
salt they launch two new flavors which
are great peanut butter cocoa chip and
dark chocolate cocoa I keep monk pack
granola bars and nut and Seed bars in
the pantry at all times they're great on
the go for a quick snack while you're
working if you don't love them as much
as I and our team do monk pack will
refund all of your money or exchange the
product whichever you prefer go to
monkpak.com and you'll get 20 off your
first order with the code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below